on va rendre hommage à l'une de vos
séquences phares de l'émission c'est mon
choix on va afficher dans l'écran des
secrets qui correspondent à nos
chroniqueurs vous allez devoir de
mineurs et devinez quel chroniqueur à ce
secret d'accord attention c'est parti
regarde on a j'ai la phobie du pas
mouillé et à votre avis à la phobie du
pain bouyer ici autour de la table
benjamin castaldi non il a la phobie des
divorces mais il a la phobie des
pensions alimentaires
oui bah regarder je vais passer parmi
vous vous allez voir tout de suite
regardé
regardez est ce que c'est que ça dit pas
mouillé regardez moi [ __ ] moody a
mouillé a même fait avec du brouillard
famille et où il y avait des gouttes
mais vraiment mais chercher mon arme
parce que pourriez manger un petit
morceau pas du tout mais pas du tout
elle a la phobie du pain mouillé c'est
comme les gens qui trompent leur tartine
dans leurs choix mais j'allais mourir
enfin voila si lille c'est dingue parce
que qui dit quand même
elle a une particularité assez spécial a
la phobie du pain oui c'est ça et niable
attachement bien il faut venir me voir
abc des hypnotiseurs des hypno
thérapeutes ça va c'est pas mal leur
phobie moi j'ai garé ma femme ma phobie
défaut des souris et souris et là ça va
mieux oui pas très bien alors qui a
apporté le café à superman y en a un qui
a porté le kata superman dans l'équipe
alors c'est quelqu'un à mon avis je
pense superman le vrai superman c'est
gilles verdez qui me regardent plutôt
sécu alors c'est qu'il y ait quoi vous
oui vous a rapporté 2,4 à superman
ouais à christopher reeve j'avais 24
super mal à l'époque oui c'est superman
c'est et j'ai travaillé pour les studios
américains commencent déjà cet appétit
comment ces histoires il est pragmatique
travailler pour les studios américains
ouais tout est normal il est en cuivre
alors c'est vrai c'était baussillon
universal il est en plein tournage et je
servais à rien comme d'habitude et m'ont
demandé d'aller chercher un café et j'ai
porté un café pour superman christopher
reeve et vous voulez avoir une anecdote
dans dix ans pourrait dire que j'ai
apporté un cas facile ne voulait pas
mais c'est pour quand même bravo ils ne
méritent pas thank you non à l'aide a
été vachement sympa dégage superman ii
j'avais dit sans sucre je suis un ancien
rappeur s'est fait de me tromper parce
que quand les invités se trompe pas
c'est chiant mais normal et l'ancien
rappeur d'isabelle morini-bosc ah oui
ben alaoui l'achète je ne sais pas vous
je suis un ancien rappeur auteur doit
être né salon alors c'est rené
malleville haruna et oui c'est un meneur
des rappeurs tout ça qu'on n'en sera pas
j'ai sorti un disque
oui large où il à flot ça va à une
vitesse par contre je sais pas qui c'est
qui connaît ici et dans vos connaître
les codex est un des plus grands jeux
truc de dieu du sud la fiesta des suds
d'accord avec koné non mais je ne
connaissais pas les gens sont déçus bien
sûr c'est ça qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
cette étude à la ja mais si le nom
régaler il ya 15000 personnes que coûte
et ça ouais et bah écoute et ils sont
toujours suivis il pourrait pas leur
faire qu'ils accueillent des jumeaux
et dire qu'à crash mais le père c'est la
même voie ouais il y avait des rémois
veut dire qu'il ya 15000 personnes qui
ont écouté sa beauté pour le rap tout
notre soutien
[Musique]
j'ai déjà mangé un rack rue les gens me
isabelle non moi je l'aurais plutôt
soignée non c'est pas moi walsh est
redessinée cru à mon avis non moi
j'aurais dit gilbert mon avis c'est
l'axé
je pense que je pense que c'est la caq a
démarré ses petits problèmes avec ses
petits problèmes je pense que c'est là
il n'était pas soigné c'est parce qu'il
était mort 1 bat bien sûr mais comment
ça s'est passé
et ben en fait je faisais du c'est
l'époque où je faisais du camping
sauvage avec des amis on se lancer des
défis et on a trouvé un rat et j'ai dit
vous me payez le repas demain le repas
d'après demain si je mange le rat non
j'ai mangé dans mort on savait pas que
ça véhicule et des maladies et eia
longue fullsound non mais sérieux on
confirme que ça véhicule débat gala
d'hier au soir vous n'avez contaminé
personne mais vous vous êtes quand même
oui à doudou la laine est de sortie non
merci seigneur c'est franchement pas
j'avoue j'aime aussi la boue c'est bon
c'est bon j'ai échappé à une prise
d'otages
à votre avis evelyne j'ai une chape et
j'ai échappé une prise d'otages à l'epa
géraldine parce qu'elle vous regardait
que c'est moi géraldine jean michel
maire de plusieurs villes ces chimères
journaliste août au matin louis évident
la grosse tête soleil oui non c'est en
2008 j'étais aux filles à ruse j'étais
en reportage dont le sol indien
ces tests ont interviewé c'est pas vous
ai pas posé la question il a bâti depuis
début janvier pascal a accéléré on n'a
rien fait et fin mars début avril 2008
dans l'océan indien gp3 comme ça c'était
où c'était où c'est au large de
madagascar
mais c'est ok l'océan on dirait mon
orthophoniste et j'ai débarqué ont
débarqué nos cités à odos
[Rires]
c'est pas bon
je suis descendu du bateau le bateau
appareillé le lendemain il est reparti
pour la méditerranée au large de la
somalie sont est attaqué par les pirates
il ya eu trente personnes à bord la
prise d'otages et durer plusieurs jours
il ya eu des blessés les forces
françaises spéciales ont attaqué les
pirates
voilà pour récupérer une partie de la
rançon ça fait la une des journaux et
j'étais dans le bateau deux jours avant
du coup j'étais bien placé pour dans le
film raconte l'histoire mais à écouter
bas bercy bravo jean michel a du talent
dans les secrets des chroniqueurs il ya
un des chroniqueurs qui a reçu des
avances de la part d'une star du tennis
alors donc c'est pas bien j'en à moi
n'ont pas ramassé qui sépare rené non
c'est pas rooney a laissé qui le petit
jeune ogoula clément gare un nom chez
king alors ces gens ne s'est pas janvier
chez qui gérait les lancers-francs
géraldine sait qui c'est moi qui donne à
ces jean borotra
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
stan smith français un homme et une
femme qui m'a fait des avancées mathurin
ventilo va oui et qu'à un corps
absolument sublime c'est parce qu'elle
était dans l'air elle passait souvent
dans les aires de repos des joueurs pour
aller se pour aller se laver mon passé
alexandre petit chien et nous et tous
les rêveurs remarqué que j'étais là et
moi je me contrefous tu es du tennis
donc j'étais dans l'air de repos je
regardais les joueurs je dessinais je
prends des notes pour un art language
autorités elles étaient sur l'air de
marisela jose qui passe alors oui et à
plusieurs fois le plusieurs fois elle
m'a parlé mais donc moi comme j'ai
écouté pas attentivement gmsl qui
comprenait mais en fait ne pas percuter
du tout peu comme dans l'émission puis
également mais est finalement quelqu'un
m'a dit mais tu lui réponds pas à ça
elle te fait des avances depuis deux
jours vous avez dit ah bon et bien
clairement nous proposait mais d'aller
dîner avec elle et puis après ben sortir
et à garantir le côté mature et puis bah
le temps que je réfléchisse elle était
passée à quelqu'un d'autre non mais j'ai
l'impression que ça aurait pu se faire
alors moi physiquement ils adorent
martina navratilova alors vous êtes vous
avez des aventures mais surtout que
celle qui est celle avec qui elle a
rompu et la moitié de sa force car oui
on les plus jeunes c'est une immense
championne avait par numéro est ce que
vous avez lu son corps de rêve parents
de se balader
quand elles ont besoin tout pas l'aider
à battre est très malade et non mais si
j'avais pas ça vous savez pas si j'ai
bien évidemment comestibles à l'ipo vous
êtes toujours comestibles attention j'ai
la phobie des trous bien entendu c'est
pas jean-michel j'ai la phobie des trous
c'est pas malin en plus non non non non
non non mais des trous de mémoire ou des
trous et roux c'est quelqu'un qui jouera
jamais oui j'ai eu une invitée qui avait
effectivement la phobie y en a plein
donc pour autobus j'ai pas compris ce
que ça voulait dire est effectivement
des cas loyer un trou elle était en
stress alarcon située à un espèce de
truc en acier rétro c'est ça ça va oui
moi j'espère qu'il fera jamais sur ce
bateau mots ce que c'était mais
sincèrement au début je me suis dit bon
c'est pas mes racines
non non moi je suis le trou du cul c'est
lent parce que des trous ils rapportent
ou alors je vais vous dire c'est clint
la phobie des jours où aller c'est que
ce qui pouvait l'être
je vous offrirai pas une perceuse pour
autant la tripe aux phobies on croit que
c'est pas connue mais c'est l'une des
phobies les plus connus mais c'est quoi
c'est à dire et donc en fait c'est
l'accumulation de petits trous donc
évidemment sur des pâles de trois
questions on est d'accord je gère par
exemple la fleur de lotus ou où
naissaient d'abeilles ou est ce vrai
quand je vois ça franchement j'ai des
vertiges et la nausée
alors j'ai pas trop sur moi
bonjour tout d'être on est là partout
massif hausse à 9 heures la phobie des
trous ouais c'est incroyable rhône et
vous avez la sopie des trous merci rené
lui l'a fait là il a la phobie des dna
glisse yeux qu'est ce cas les trous bah
voila j'ai peur des ananas
c'est vrai que vous les hameaux en fait
vous les avez trimestre c'est mon choix
là mais il ya un mec qui a peur des
ananas et là je me souviens très bien de
cette émission qui a peur des dallas pas
moi sinon bah non je pense que bernard
non regarde c'est déjà fait moi qui sape
a trait aux dépens des dallas j'ai la
phobie des ananas
non non non non non non non non je suis
levé phobique en vapeur des samossas ces
éléments marignan
[Applaudissements]
samatan des gens le catch le car est en
moi je le paie alors allez-y
mathé non mais c'est vrai oui oui non
mais je redoutais un petit peu en plus
le ils mangent venir chez vous et
évelyne le puits de possibles est rendu
compte et j'ai perdu connaissance
non c'est complètement irrationnel
d'ailleurs je vais aller le ch et un
hypnothérapeute effectivement en début
d'année s'est complètement vrai nom mais
j'ai eu la chance de 2,2 partie revient
à tahiti et le les organisateurs le
voulant faire plaisir le m'ont fait
faire une randonnée en quad au milieu de
nathan et on a fait un une partie dans
un champs d'ananas et j'ai failli perdre
connaissance
non non la mer plus grande phobie
maquettes et les gens pour lui qui se
rêve est perturbé mais socialement parme
en parlant ne les gens ne comprennent sa
voix par exemple les gens ne comprennent
pas que j'ai la phobie des noix de cajou
et magali mentation non mais
[Rires]
en diniz de pardon j'ai reçu pour 50000
euros de cadeaux
comprenez bien que c'est pas moi qui ai
demandé pardon j'allais dire syrie mais
dans l'intitulé comprenez bien que c'est
pas moi qui ai demandé par donc voila
merci c'est qu' il en reste peu de ars
qui géraldine c'est une race est la plus
riche en oeufs alors j'étais gérer d'une
marque de cosmétiques quand j'étais
mannequin d'accord égérie au monde
non on avait tous les tous les pays sauf
le royaume uni et un jour je vais chez
harrods et je suis dans les cours alors
à rhodes c'est quoi ces magasins c'est
l'équivalent donne du printemps et des
galeries lafayette à eau à londres voilà
à londres ah oui et je suis je suis dans
les couloirs et je vois ma photo partout
non et en fait il n'avait pas le droit
d'utiliser ma photo est donc le booker
de mon agence de mannequins après cette
marque où l'on a négocié et où est
d'avoir une rallonge hebinger 50 euros
cinquante mille euros de cadeaux dans la
boutique non la route
j'ai un côté a pretty woman c'est
incroyable voit qu'une gamme de qualité
c'est fou prester dingue j'avais pris
plein de trucs vous rendez compte mais
ça c'est le rêve de tout le monde est
rentré dans un super je vous montrais
galeries lafayette ou bien moi
j'adorerais mois rentrée pariente chez
lidl et j'ai cinquante mille euros pour
50000 euros chez lidl frère tu repars
directement de la boutique
j'adorerais saurait s'y serait magique
moi je suis fou des baskets lidl qui
sont en rupture de stock je laissais
arrivé tout ça c'est impossible les
arriérés bah non je le dis si à l'époque
me les avoir ça m'arrangerait au
marqueur noir ils partent à 2000 2500 je
sais les basques mon chien urines tout
le passé sur la personne avec qui je vis
momie reste que castaldi
vous avez bien compris que c'est
castaldi qui longe chien la manche est
jaloux au fait il est il est jaloux
darwin nom de ma famille sans territoire
non mais il passe derrière et lui pis
mais un nom dessus quoi vincent
territoire et ses terres et votre chien
à les voir un comportementaliste pour
chien boxer mais c'est vrai je fais pipi
sur votre femme ouais et quand il n'est
pas content il a faibli sur son oreiller
même dans le lit non c'est pas nouveau
c'est que c'est des villes entières
[Applaudissements]
chaussures je n'ai pas de comptes depuis
toutes ces années
on démarre ce soir à pêcher ce lundi
c'est moi
[Applaudissements]